well the interesting thing about service
work now that you say it is a lot of the
creative class is moving into this work
and I think that's why you see such a
revolution and I mean you know this
fellow Matt craft Crawford who sometimes
criticizes me I have no beef with the
guy who says he left his ph.d and went
back to open his motorcycle shop well he
had the skills and the capability to
make a great motorcycle shop you see so
many members of the of the creative
class going into you know home repair or
you know or food the whole revolution
that's going on in food and restaurants
and organic products in Canada where we
live this whole thing with ice wine and
upgrading of ice wine so you see the
members of the creative class going into
this stuff and saying oh that's really
interesting in terms of skills I think
our work has helped us identify this I
think in the united states in canada and
europe we've all been in an asian we've
all been told be smart that's what my
parents said my dad said i work in the
factory rich and they sent me to
Catholic school Queen of Peace of all
places boys high school in north
arlington new jersey in the hardest
sopranos country and what why they send
us their two boys richard him Robert
they wanted us have a good education
that was the ticket to upward mobility
and you got a career so we went to
rutgers college got garden state
scholarships and figured out i I'm ager
dinner been planning and figured out a
kind it was the way into the economy I
think now though that's not enough of
course an education is helpful and our
work suggests that the cognitive skills
the knowledge skills are only part of it
actually it's the social skills that
really matter and and if I had to be
really blunt and give kind of business
advice the one thing that we don't teach
I teach in a business school the one
thing thing that we don't teach in the
business school that we don't teach in
school is not only entrepreneurship we
don't teach people how to sell it's been
the hardest thing I've ever had to learn
how do you sell how do you pitch a book
project how do you and you know this to
you had to build a company we have kids
and I try to hire people and they say
I'll come work for you but I don't want
to sell well I mean I hate to say it in
this kind of economy that we have this
fragmented with then being calls a free
agent economy which I think can be
better for lots of people that if we
have the right social supports and right
benefit systems we have to set we have
to sell more so those the social skills
the team building the selling the other
part it was education and we talk more
about this but I
always hated school from day one I never
liked it I never felt it was an
education system I felt it was an
education school maybe it's cuz i went
with nuns and ida scars to prove it have
that effect yeah but i've been doing but
i never liked it in college I never went
to class and you know what's interesting
about this you know and I hung out with
my friends and we talked about
interesting stuff and we have is you
know kind of wide-ranging seminar over
beers at night but you know whether it's
steve jobs or Michael Dell or Bill Gates
people who are far more business savvy
than I'll ever be or most of us
ninety-nine point nine percent of us all
of them dropped out of school so that's
telling me that something in the system
is broken and I think one of the great
things about technology and I don't want
to overblow technology but we both love
it I think the technology enables kids
to learn without having to be stuck in
these many stultifying places called
schools and if we look at learning less
as real estate as you know send the kid
to a school and more as development I
mean Ken Robinson nails this you know
when he when he talks about it like
ninety nine percent of three year old
scores creative they go to school for a
few years it's down to 50 by the time
they're teenagers it's 10 and by the
time they're my age it's like one
percent I forgetting statistics but
there's something like that so I think
we have to build institutions not of
education but of learning and those are
going to have to be human centered and
individual and I think the technology
gives us a chance but you know when Bill
Gates said the school system is broken
he's right when Peter Drucker said I can
the research university will not survive
the transition to the knowledge-based
capitalism the way we deliver learning
is very broken and very in unhuman so it
seems to me that's got to be a first
principle we've got to somehow you know
it's really interesting in the 1800's we
built a system of mass public education
1850s and 60s in the 1890s we started to
really work on the colleges in the
universities and build them up after the
war we had the GI Bill and we made
education available to working-class
people like me my dad went to septa my
grandfather had none my dad 7th grade I
have a university education I think what
we have to do now to remake this system
is bigger than all of that combined and
here we think about tweaking the schools
at the margin if we're really going to
build this kind of creative society we
have to completely reinvent the way
human beings develop and learn
beneath all of my writing and I often
say my much better verbal I try to write
but I'm not a great writer and it's hard
for me and I'm an academic so that makes
it worse I'm in okay talker so all of my
work really is about this question of
institutional redesign I mean from the
beginning of my work in the in the late
eighteen a late 1980s and 1990s was
always about institutional design and I
think our institutions the mass
production institutions the fordyce
institutions have been broken now for a
generation and yet nobody wants to
confront it and I don't understand why
you know manzer Olson wrote the real key
to the decline of Nations was when these
institutions become he called it
sclerotic institutional sclerosis he
said why regions decline why nations
decline why companies decline is very
simple these institutions are built
they're great for the time they're built
they work like clockwork and then over
time is the environment changes or they
just become more rigid in bureaucratic
and sclerotic and he said that sometimes
why history moves from the Netherlands
to England to the United States you know
for the east coast to the west coast and
now some say I think it's early in this
to age of the Asian century but I think
the bigger question and I think what the
United States has been uncanny you know
my dad used to say this he said rich you
know when I signed up for the army
remember the depression how down we were
and then when I signed it for the army
that we had Doughboy hats and he's old
boots and they gave us broomsticks he
said the mobilization institutional
redid say institutional Versailles the
mobilization for the war and the
factories got changed and the government
got into it and boy we turned on a dime
I am puzzled as an American living in
Canada why we can't do this anymore why
we're so locked in is the word I think
economist would use and I don't know
what it's going to take to blow that up
but but the interesting thing is it's
not happening anywhere in the world it's
not like you can click to China and say
they're redesigning their institutions
or Brazil and say they're redesigning
their institutions it's almost as this
everyone is stuck in the same place it
seems to me that the mental models and
frameworks of the Ford astronomy of the
mass production economy are so powerful
and so deeply ingrained in the way we
think it's hard to think in other terms
and so what I think happened actually is
people create their own safe space so
the folks in Silicon Valley said screw
that
I'm not going to go try to rebuild
industrial for dizzam I'm going to carve
out a really cool thing here in Silicon
Valley for me you know I'm not going to
take this on and redo arts education I'm
going to build a little interesting arts
district in my community so I think
there's enough space and flexibility in
the system that people could find their
niche so to speak but I think the bigger
question is one of institutional
redesign and and and for folks you know
listening in the clock of history is
always ticking it doesn't stop so it's
not like history stops we've reached the
end of history in the last man the clock
of history text sooner or later some
group of people somewhere someplace will
figure this out and as they figure it
out and get this institutional redesign
right they'll get what huge advantage
Jude's competitive advantage Jude's
first mover advantage and they'll
eclipse us now I still think we have a
little time because these are
generational processes but but
somebody's got to wake up and and and
I'll hopefully hopefully it'll happen
soon hopefully that's what this event
were going through this economic shock
we're going through hopefully it allow
people to wake up and say these are the
new kinds of institutions first we have
to take down the old ones that don't
work anymore that's a big job and
secondly here are the new kinds of
institutions we have to build to make a
prosperous a more creative more
productive better society